the 1,300 meter long eastside gallery is
the longest remaining section of the
berlin wall
for decades the wall divided the city
and germany after it came down artists
from around the world came to paint the
east side of this remaining segment the
gallery became a major tourist
attraction and a symbol of freedom and
human rights
I remember watching when they first
knocked it down
so I mean more than the graffiti the
historical meaning is more important I
think in some ways I think it's
important to remind what happened here
so I think it's very like representative
and all these artists not just art it's
it has a deeper meaning t Renoir was one
of the artists involved he was there
when the project got underway in
February 1990 Susan Matheson is a tempie
between March and September 1990 artists
from around the world came here to
Berlin to paint the wall there was a lot
of euphoria everyone thought freedom is
coming everything will be better
everything will be great a new
documentary film follows some of the
more than 100 artists from 21 countries
who flocked to the stretch of wall
running along the ship lay River they
wanted their artworks to express the joy
they felt after the wall came down
the film also explores the restoration
that took place in 2009 to repair the
damage caused by vandalism and erosion
it also looks at the ongoing conflicts
between artists investors residents and
Berlin's city planners the East Side
Gallery is on prime real estate with a
view of the river that's made it very
attractive to developers
this arenas development plan called for
a part of the wall to be knocked down
even though it was supposed to be a
protected structure I doubt anyone wants
the east side gallery to disappear we
need a suitable urban planning concept
that's Berlin's job and as the federal
government will help finance it a symbol
of freedom or a free-for-all for
developers for now this cultural icon is
here to stay